ما شهدناه هنا حرفيًا
هو صواريخ أخرى، انظر هنا،
ترى Tracer F، وصواريخ القبة الحديدية
تأتي لاعتراض الصواريخ
القادمة من غزة، وستسمع
الانفجارات هناك، ويتم إطلاق القبة الحديدية في
كل مكان حولنا الآن.
تضيء السماء هنا انفجارات
القبة الحديدية التي تعترض الصواريخ
التي يتم إطلاقها من غزة على بعد
بضعة أميال فقط وتنفجر حرفيًا
في السماء فوقنا هنا، هذا ما
رأيناه يحدث خلال الـ
10 أو 15 دقيقة الماضية
صواريخ القبة الحديدية التي يقومون بتتبعها
واعتراضها لتلك الصواريخ التي تأتي
من
غزة، أصبحوا قادرين على اكتشاف المكان الذي
تحلق فيه الصواريخ، ثم
أطلقوا صواريخ أيونوني
واعترضوها في الهواء، يمكنك
فقط رؤية أين أين
كان الانفجار في السماء فوقنا الآن
يتم إطلاق صاروخ آخر هناك
جون إذا كان بإمكانك رؤيته يطير هنا
وخلفنا هنا فوق غزة أيضًا
إنهم يطيرون هناك صاروخ آخر قادم
سألتزم الصمت نحن  هل يمكن
[موسيقى]
الاستماع إلى أن النظام الدفاعي الأيوني الإسرائيلي
يعمل على حماية شعب
إسرائيل هذا المساء، تلك الصواريخ
تخرج من غزة ربما على بعد بئرين ونصف،
غزة على بعد ميلين ونصف،
الصواريخ القادمة من داخل غزة هناك
أه ل  المواطنين
المدنيين الإسرائيليين الذين يعيشون في بلدات
ساكي أشلون أشدود الذين يعيشون على طول أه على
طول الساحل هنا صواريخ القبة الحديدية
تحميهم
وعائلاتهم عندما نتحدث عن
الأراضي الفلسطينية نحن نتحدث بشكل عام
عن الضفة الغربية وغزة ولكن
هنا  نحن نركز فقط على غزة حيث
تسيطر إسرائيل على البحر
والحدود الشمالية والحدود الشرقية، كيف يمكن أن
يحدث هذا لأخذ إسرائيل على حين
غرة، نعم هذا سؤال عظيم حقًا
أورين لأن ما
تنظر إليه هنا هو هذه
المنطقة الصغيرة حقًا  من الأراضي مكتظة
بالسكان كما ذكرت سابقًا أه
لكن حقيقة الأمر هي أن
الفلسطينيين، غوريلا حماس، كانوا
يبحثون حقًا عن كيفية التحايل على
المخابرات الإسرائيلية، وكانوا يعلمون أنه
يتعين عليهم التخلص من الهواتف التي كانوا يعلمون أنهم
مضطرون إليها  في الأساس استخدموا السعاة ووسائل
أخرى أكثر بدائية أه
للتواصل مع بعضهم البعض وعندما
فعلوا ذلك، كانوا قادرين على ذلك، يبدو
أنه منع الإسرائيليين من
معرفة ما كانوا يعتزمون فعله حقًا،
وأعتقد أن هذا أعطاهم عنصر المفاجأة
في هذا  إذا قلت وسائل بدائية ومع
ذلك فإن إسرائيل معروفة بقدرتها
بصراحة على تكنولوجيا التجسس سواء كان ذلك
من الجو أو
اعتراض الإشارات، فهل كانت حماس قد انخفضت ببساطة
إلى قدرة إسرائيل على التقاط
أي من هذا، وهو ما كان يجب أن يكون
كبيرًا  خلية لتنفيذ هذا، نعم
أعتقد أنه كان كذلك والأمر
المثير للاهتمام حقًا بشأن هذا هو حقيقة
أنك تعرف عندما تذهب إلى أه هذه المنطقة
وتنظر إلى جميع
العناصر المختلفة الموجودة هنا،
يمكنك أن ترى أن إسرائيل  لقد كان
محاطًا بالفعل بالعديد من المنافسين المختلفين في
هذه المرحلة بالذات وأعداء سابقين،
بعضهم أعداء حاليين،
وحقيقة أنهم تمكنوا من
القيام بذلك أعتقد أنها تشير إلى أنهم ذهبوا إلى
مستوى منخفض من أجل منع وسائل التكنولوجيا الفائقة
الكشف وهذا سمح لهم
بالدخول وفي الجوهر أه فاجأ
الإسرائيليين بطريقة
لم يتوقعوها وفي كثير من النواحي
تعتقد أن المفاجآت هي شيء
لا تتوقعه ولكن هذا
أكثر من ذلك  يصل الأمر إلى مستوى أعمق
من
ذلك